hey there and welcome to this motion
science podcast I'm Cameron and in
today's episode we're going to talk
about freelancing and in particular
we're going to talk about the three key
points that you need to focus on right
now to become a successful freelancer
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the podcast as
I said I'm Cameron and you already know
that and we're talking about the three
key points today to focus on to become a
successful freelancer I get asked all
the time you know what should I be
focused on shall be focused on the
software shall be focused on my reel
should I be focused on you know getting
the work
what should I focus on well there's
several things you could focus on but
for me there's three main key points
that are very very important for you to
focus on so that you do become
successful as a freelancer and I'm
telling you this from experience I
started freelancing back in 2007 I did
it remotely for the most part sometimes
I would travel to production studios on
location but I tried to stay remote for
the most part and I learned a lot about
what works and wasn't what doesn't work
and freelancing so let's talk about the
first thing the first thing is you need
to get very very clear you need to get
super clear on what type of freelancer
you want to be okay that can be a
numerous it can be numerous things to
pay on what you want to do so there's
things like there's freelance
generalists
there's freelance specialists there's
remote artists like myself there's on
location artists depending on where you
live that might be something that's you
know something you're able to do so
those are kind of its like some typical
like generalised terms for what you
could be as a freelancer right so the
first one is a generalist so a
generalist is pretty much like what I
did okay a generalist can do many things
well now you don't want to be a
generalist and know what I do you know
let's say design and motion and
compositing and visual effects but not
do it very well so if you're a
generalist you need to be very well
rounded right you can't be strictly an
animator well you can be strictly an
animator and be a generalist
and maybe that's something like you know
you know character animation
and you're really good at logo animation
or are you really good at particle
animation maybe that's the type of
generalist you are or like I said maybe
you're a journalist like me and you can
design style frames you can animate you
can animate style frames right like you
can take you can design the style frames
and then you can come back and you can
actually animate those stuff frames or
you're really good at animating and
designing maybe you can also do a really
good overall polish maybe you're good
working with typography
so there's lots of different kind of
subcategories for being a generalist but
then there's also being a specialist and
a specialist is just as powerful as
being a generalist specialist could be
like you're only focused in on animating
cameras maybe you only animate 3d
cameras or maybe you only do character
animation or maybe you only do vector
based style frames maybe you only work
on particle effects and Houdini or
another 3d package or maybe you're a 3d
modeler so that's a specialist that's
that's someone who really focuses on one
particular area and they're really
really good at that particular area and
they get hired for that one talent now
in my own personal experience I did work
for studios and to me they were looking
more for generalists depending on what
the project was their worst times we'd
bring in specialists or they'd bring in
specialists but there's a lot of
journalists working with us then there's
also like you can be a remote artist so
a remote remote artist means that you're
working from your own home studio in
your own city and you work remotely
through the internet and you work with
producers or teams and you do you know
your piece of the project a lot of times
remote specialist or generalist you get
you know a small piece of a project and
there's a big team and maybe you're just
filling a gap for a team that team could
be on location in a studio in a city and
you're just you know filling in the gaps
you can also be an on location
a freelancer which means that you know
if you do live in a large city like I
live in America and in America there's a
lot of work to be found in Los Angeles
there's a lot of work to be found in New
York Seattle larger cities like that I'm
in a smaller city in Florida and I
couldn't get the type of work I want to
do here on location before this I lived
in Kansas City and Kansas City was very
challenging to get on location work
because there's a lot of regional work
but I wanted higher end work and I
wanted international work and that was
on the coast so that's why I had to be a
remote specialist because I didn't want
to travel I had kids you know when I
started I had small kids and I chose to
be close to them so if you live in a
larger city and you have opportunities
to work for different studios or
agencies that's a great fit as well
something else I want to talk about just
really briefly is when you're deciding
what type of freelancer you want to be
general specialists remote on location
you don't need to know all the
software's so a lot a lot of freelancers
or people are thinking about going
freelance get caught up in the idea that
they have to learn After Effects and
cinema 4d and Houdini and and you know
all the different plugins and things
like that you don't need to know all of
that just focus in on what it is that
you do need to to know to be really good
at whatever type of freelancer you are
so you know for me again I'll go back to
me if as a journalist I needed to know
After Effects really well and I needed a
no Photoshop and illustrator and that
was for design purposes now I did move
into designing more inside of After
Effects and if you've taken into my
courses you'll see that I do most of my
design in After Effects these days but
starting out it was important I knew
Photoshop and illustrator in addition to
this to After Effects and then as time
moved on I needed to know cinema 4d but
I didn't have to know all about cinema
4d you know I didn't have to know I got
pretty good at animating
objects in cinema 40 as well as cameras
in cinema 4d but I
I suck at texturing I suck at modeling I
don't want to touch modeling I'm okay at
lighting but if I'm hired for a project
I'm just straight up with you know I'm
very straight with the producers or the
team and I say hey I don't model it you
guys need to bring someone in to do that
you hand me a model with a texture on it
I can animate it for you but I found
that most of my work was then falling
into After Effects so it just depends
what you want to do you know if you're
gonna go into particle systems you
ponied to know a particular or stardust
which are too big particle plugins
inside of After Effects at the time of
this recording or there's particle
systems like X particles and cinema 4d
so it just depends where you want to go
okay so that's the first thing the
second key point that you need to focus
on to become a successful freelancer is
branding branding can be many things but
the most important things that you need
to focus on instead of branding are two
things and that's your website and your
reel now I'll talk about the website
first okay so for the website it's you
don't need to have a complicated website
right you just need to have one or two
pages or maybe three pages but nothing
more than three pages the three pages
could be something like you know page
one is your home page and you come that
home page and it's got your reel in
there and maybe page two is your about
page it's just a blurb about you and
maybe page three is your contact
information or maybe it's individual
projects
if those individual projects are style
frames or they're animated pieces you
know whatever it is maybe on the about
page you put a contact information
that's really important as well you
could go one page I've done that in the
past and I've seen it work for other
freelancers very very well and the one
page just has your reel on it about you
and contact and that's it
right so it's really important that you
have a little blurb about you on that
website because
when a producer is looking to hire a
freelancer if they've never worked with
you before they want to know just a
little bit about you and that's just one
short paragraph maybe two short
paragraphs and that's just good the
writing the description about you is
gonna tell them a lot just in those
words about who you are as a person in
general right and and I can say like
maybe you have a like a small picture
there with you as well on the about page
and that's gonna tell them that you know
you know my parents has say a lot so if
the photos there they're mainly gonna
get a read on who you are but in your
writing they're gonna get a sense of you
know kind of like your personality are
you sarcastic are you funny
are you very dry straightforward are you
delivering the facts or you put some
humor in there it's kind of tell them a
little bit about you
I'm unfortunately in our industry
there's some egos right and from my
experience even if an if a person is
very very talented if the ego gets in
the way the producers aren't gonna bring
that person back so the about you is
just for a new free a new company that's
looking to hire you just to so they get
to know you a little bit of course once
a company hires you if you impress them
they're gonna keep coming back to you
and about you is not important anymore
right but and then once you your career
kind of you know takes off you'll find
that you don't have to have new clients
coming in you just need a handful of
good clients you know five to ten
awesome clients will keep you busy all
year round right it'll it'll feed you
it'll feed your family and that's all
you need it's just a handful of clients
so that's the about you now the the next
thing is the real and before I talk
about the real the contact for contact
you don't have to put your phone number
it's it's up to you it's questionable if
you want to do it or not sub-q I never
did actually I did do it a couple times
but I found it wasn't necessary you just
need that email but you need it front
and center you need to let them know
easily how to contact
now let's talk about the real the real
needs to be typically 60 to 60 seconds
to 90 seconds I don't advise anything
over 90 seconds we are overloaded with
content these days and people will lose
attention the their attention to you is
going to fade very quickly after 90
seconds and and in the past I had a
small boutique motion graphic studio and
I was a creative director there and I
was hit with reels all the time and
emails with those reels that you know
attached those reels and I mean I found
that after 90 seconds I'm checked out
it's just too much you can show a lot
you can show everything about your
talent who you are in 60 90 seconds even
30 seconds works so in that reel you
need to make it unique to you and a lot
of that depends on the music and that
also shows some of your personality with
that music you need to show your best
work period if you're trying to fill up
a reel to 60 seconds and you find that
you've got 30 seconds of a really
awesome work in there and then there's
gonna be 30 seconds is kind of like
mediocre work cut it out make your reel
30 seconds okay if you if you include
the work in there that's your best work
it's gotta be also work that you want
more of because what you're doing is
you're putting your best work out there
to a producer who's looking for that
type of work and it's going that
preacher is going to hire you based on
that work so it's just a big cycle so
you are putting out to the world in your
real work that you want more of and then
that work is going to come to you I
meant for example like I don't enjoy
doing character animation okay and I
have done some character animation in
the past multiple projects and it's
because the clients I had knew what I
was capable of so they would say hey
we've got a character piece we know you
don't like doing that but can you help
us out and do that sure
I'll do it for you but I'm never going
to show that character animation on my
reel because I don't want more
that work from new clients I don't want
to advertise to the world hey I can do
character animation and then I start
getting more of that I you know I'm
filled that creatively filled with work
like particle effects and and polishes
and lighting and really dark moody work
and that's what it really fills my soul
so that's what's gonna be on my reel
because I want more of it for those of
you who are creating a reel and you
don't have enough work to really show
off your talent maybe you only have 10
15 seconds of really awesome work and
the rest of your work is stuff that you
don't want will create spec work I talk
about this all the time but my first
several reels were mostly filled with
spec work now what is spec work spec
work is not work that I'm getting from a
client I don't believe I'm not a big
believer at all and doing free work for
clients spec work for clients I've done
it a couple times in my life I'm saying
I'm literally saying two or three times
in 12 13 14 years of freelancing it
never amounted to anything it was always
the promise of hey if this turns out
awesome we're gonna going to come back
to you with all this work it's gonna be
amazing a lot of money and never works
out right I mean I same throat my
friends they've done the same thing and
it's very rare for it to come back and
be a big project it actually pays you so
I am NOT a believer in spec work you
have a unique talent as a motion
designer and you should be paid for that
even if it's a lower budget project you
should be paid something for that okay
so anyways if you don't have the work to
fill your reel make spec work go home
create the work that you want more of if
you love doing textured work or 3d work
or logo animations just create it right
like just let's say like I take a logo
like coca-cola or um you know anything
any type of make up a logo and animate
it and make it do what you think is is
just gonna sell and it's just really
awesome if people if creative directors
and producers see that and they see that
you have talent you will get hired based
on that they're not gonna come to you
and say hey did you really do this this
animation right here for
for this company they just want to see
what you've done and know that you did
it and then they're gonna hire you based
on that now that brings up one caveat
one not caveat tangent I just want to
talk about very quickly and that is
don't ever show someone else's work on
your reel that you didn't have a heavy
hand in okay this has happened to me in
the past what's happened to my friends
in the past where let's say I worked on
a 5-10 second piece and I basically did
90% of the look the design the animation
and then another four the answer came in
and he did some expressions on one
animation piece well he took that piece
and he showed it off on his reel which
is a bunch of crap right because he
didn't do that piece he did he just came
up with an expression a number to plug
into my animation so it wasn't his right
to take that piece and show it off as
his work I called him out on it told him
hey you need to remove it from your reel
and he did it right because a producer
or a creative director wants to know
that you did that piece if if you have
some really strong pieces but you're
let's say you're a specialist and all
you do is a certain piece of that image
then just just call it out you can put
that in the description below your reel
you can break down your reel and say
like you know I do particle effects
every particle effects we see in these
shots is from me let producers know be
upfront be straight with whoever it is
trying to hire you even if it's an end
consumer be straight with them they'll
appreciate it in the end and you're
going to be in a better place with them
as well okay so one more one more key
point were gonna talk about key point
number three and this is ideal clients
okay once you've got you know what could
type of freelancer you want to be you've
got some branding out there because this
your branding on the online is what is
going to attract that work to you you
need to attract your ideal client so you
need to get super clear on who your
ideal client is right you need to figure
that out so is your ideal client is it a
production studio is
it a movie studio is it an end business
is it an end consumer is it an agency
there's a lot of in clients and you need
to decide who it is that you want to
work for now maybe you don't know who it
is that you want to work for and that's
okay too it's okay to kind of dive in
and explore that but just just be aware
of who you think your ideal client
should be now for me I found that I
really enjoyed working with production
houses other teams of motion designers
so that means that production companies
like digital kitchen or prologue films
would hire me to come in and work on
these pieces for like film titles or or
advertisements and I would work for the
most part with teams of other people
maybe it's one other person maybe it's
three other guys maybe it's a whole you
know big team but I found that I really
enjoyed working with in with production
studios and producers and creative
directors I just gelled better with that
with those types of people I there was
times I worked for agencies it wasn't
for me the whole agency mentality just I
didn't gel with that and that was okay
right there's a lot of other motion
designers who do really well with that
um I also found that the times that I
worked with like an end client as like a
business you know I did a lot of that
sometimes it would work sometimes it
wouldn't work um I found a lot of times
there was maybe some higher budgets
there but it just wasn't worth it to me
I found that ultimately my sweet spot
like I said was production studios
because they they knew what my talents
were they respected my time they
respected my my creativity I got paid
really well to work with them and it was
fun I would learn a lot from other
motion designers even working remotely
like we would past project files back
and forth depending on the job and I
learned a lot that way so also with an
ideal client you need to manage
expectations okay so once you get a
client to come in to you and use your
services you need to manage what their
expectations are which is also
I found that production studios it was
much easier to do that because they did
understand that motion design takes a
lot of time let's be honest like there
are certain consumers or businesses out
there that think that the motion design
can be done really quick like you click
a button boom it's done it's animated
look at that Wow well that's not the
case right so managing expectations if
you're working with a business who
doesn't understand or even an
advertising company who doesn't
understand how long motion design takes
or they don't understand the process of
what it takes you need to manage their
expectations you need to be upfront and
say ok this is how it works this is how
I work and this is how long it's going
to take this is what's kind of cost
if managing expectations also has to do
with like things like revisions like
you're gonna get two rounds of revisions
maybe three rounds of revisions after
that the fees got to go up there's also
different stages there's a rough stage
you have to approve the rough the rough
draft of my design you have to approve
the rough draft of my animation you have
to approve the eighty-five percent
finished piece and then we're going to
polish and we're you know it's a much
easier process if you manage their
expectations and one other point about
having an ideal client is you need to
over deliver to your client and if you
respect your client you over deliver to
what their expectations are they're
going to respect you to the highest
standing and they're gonna keep coming
back for more right over delivering
doesn't mean that I'm working I'm you
know I said I would give it 40 hours and
I'm gonna give it 60 hours and call good
no that's not over delivering that's
that's killing yourself not getting paid
for it we're delivering maybe means that
the deadline is 5 o'clock on Friday I'm
going to deliver it to you at 4 o'clock
on Friday so you're you're not freaking
out the producer is not freaking out I'm
gonna deliver just right ahead of
schedule I'm going to maybe add in a few
little minut details that I know they're
going to be ok with to just really take
that piece to the next level
and and come in on budget as well coming
on time on budget and and you know added
a few little details if it's that if
it's gonna be okay to do that you don't
want to come into a piece at the very
end and say oh by the way I added this
design element right here what do you
think it's awesome although I know you
guys are gonna love it they're like what
do you mean you can't add that so it
just depends on what the client how the
client is what the project is in terms
of over-delivering but if you always
deliver on time on budget that goes
miles and miles with clients so those
are my three key points to focus on to
become a successful freelancer like I
said I get asked all the time what
should I do to become successful just
focus on the type of freelancer you want
to be that goes very deep into
software's and-and-and what it is that
you actually want to do focus on your
branding and that's your online presence
and focus on getting your ideal client
and you will be good to go so that's
what I've got for you if you want to
dive even deeper into how to become a
successful freelancer I do have a course
through motion science TV called the
freelance effect it goes into these
three key points even deeper and it goes
into three or four more points in
addition to these that go very deep it's
a course of a setup to set you up for
success as a freelancer because like I
said I've done this for many many many
years I've always charged a premium for
my services I've always gotten paid for
those services and I've got a lot of
killer work to show based on those
philosophies so I hope you enjoyed this
video and until next time I'm Cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]